اه
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله حي على الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه الله
اكبر لا اله الا الله
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدلوا
استووا ان شاء الله مائده
[Silence]
الله الحمد لله رب
الع مالك
يوم واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط راط المستقيم صراط
الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
لتجدن اشد الناس عداوه للذين امنوا اليهود
والذين
اشركوا
ولتجدن
اقربهن وده للذين امنوا الذين قالوا انا
نصارى ذلك
بان منهم
قسيين ورهبانا وانهم لا
يستكبرون واذا سمعوا ما انزل الى الرسول
ترى اعينهم تفيض من الدمع مما عرفوا من
الحق يقولون ربنا
امنا فاكتبنا مع
الشاهدين وما لنا نؤمن بالله وما
جاءنا من الحق ونطمع ان يدخل
خلنا ونطمع ان يدخلنا ربنا مع القوم
الصالحين فاثابهم الله بما قالوا
جنات تجري من تحتها
الانهار خالدين
فيها وذلك جزاء
ء
المحسنين والذين كفروا وكذبوا
باياتنا
اولئك
اولئك اصحاب الجحيم
الله
سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحم الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تحرموا طيبات ما
احل الله لكم ولا تعتدوا ان الله لا يحب
المعتدين وكلوا مما رزقكم الله حلالا
طيبا واتقوا الله الذي انتم به
مؤمنون لا يؤاخذكم الله باللغو في ايمانكم
ولكن
يؤاخذكم بما عقدتم
الايمان ولكن
يؤاخذكم بما عقدتم الايمان
فكفارته
فكفارته اطعام عشره مساكين من اوس ط ما
تطعمون
اهليكم او كسوتهم او تحرير
رقبه فمن لم يجد فصيام ثلاثه
ايام ذلك كفاره ايمانكم اذا
حلفتم واحفظوا يبين الله لكم
اياته
لعلكم تؤمنون
[Silence]
سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله لمن حمده
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله மஹ
‏donation
as wiல
as and
make apprate andch
your now part of it so the be
needed we use the mon
‏so the
year so the first
frices and to ask for your and
support
after give us coule of minut of time to
talk to you and see if we can some funds
ইনশল্লাহ
pleasன்
এট
make
it
dely
because over
time so you can make 12 payம
[Silence]
‏time pleas পিজ মি বদ জাব জাজাকমুল্লাহ
খর
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدلوا
استووا سو
الصف الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين كذلك يبين الله لكم اياته لعلكم
تشكرون يا ايها الذين امنوا انما الخمر
والميسر والانصاب والازلام
رجس رجس من عمل الشيطان
فاجتنبوه لعلكم
تفلحون انما يريد الشيطان ان يوقع بينكم
العداوه والبغضاء في الخمر
والميسر ويصدكم عن ذكر الله وعن الصلاه
فهل انتم
منتهون واطيعوا الله واطيعوا الرسول
واحذروا
فان توليتم فاعلموا انما على رسولنا
البلاغ
المبين ليس على الذين امنوا وعملوا
الصالحات جناح فيما
طعموا اذا ما اتقوا وامنوا وعملوا
الصالحات ثم اتقوا وامنوا ثم اتقوا
واحسنوا
والله يحب المحسنين.
يا ايها الذين امنوا
ليبلونكم الله بشيء من
الصيد
ليبلونكم الله بشيء من الصيد تناله ايديكم
ورماحكم ليعلم الله من يخافه
بالغيب فمن اعتدى بعد ذلك فله عذاب اليم
يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تقتلوا الصيد
وانتم حرم
الا يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تقتلوا الصيد
وانتم
حرم ومن قتله منكم
متعمدا
فجزاء مثل ما قتل فجزاء
مثل ما قتل من النعم يحكم به ذوى عدل
منكم يحكم به ذوى عدل منكم هديا بالغ
الكعبه او
كفاره او كفاره طعام مساكين او عدل ذلك
صياما ليذوق وبال
امره عفى الله
عما سلف ومن عاد فينتقم الله منه والله
عزيز ذو
انتقام احل لكم صيد البحر وطعامه متاعا
لكم
وللسياره وحرم عليكم صيد البر ما دمتم
حرما واتقوا الله
واعلموا واتقوا الله الذي اليه
تحشرون جعل الله الكعبه البيت الحرام
قياما للناس والهدي
والقلائد ذ جعل الله الكعبه البيت الحرام
قياما للناس والشهر الحرام والهدي
والقلائد ذلك لتعلموا ان الله يعلم ما في
السماوات وما في الارض وان الله بكل شيء
عليم اعلموا ان الله
شديد
العقاب اعلموا ان الله شديد العقاب وان
الله غفور
رحيم ما على الرسول ول الا
البلاغ والله يعلم ما تبدون وما
تكتمون قل لا يستوي الخبيث والطيب ولو
اعجبك كثره
الخبيث فاتقوا الله يا اولي الالباب لعلكم
تفلحون يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تسالوا عن
اشياء ان تبد لكم
تسؤكم وان تسالوا عنها حين ينزل القران
تبد لكم عفى الله عنها والله غفور
حليم قد سالها قوم من قبلكم ثم اصبحوا بها
كافرين ما جعل الله من
بحيره ولا
سائبه ولا وصيله ولا حام
ولكن الذين كفروا يفترون على الله
الكذب واكثرهم لا
يعقلون واذا قيل لهم تعالوا الى ما انزل
الله والى
الرسول قالوا حسبنا ما وجدنا عليه
اباءنا اولو كان
اباؤهم لا يعلمون
شيئا ولا يهتدون
الله
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين يا ايها الذين امنوا عليكم انفسكم لا
يضركم من ضل اذا
اهتديتم الى الله مرجعكم جميعا
فينبئكم بما كنتم
تعملون يا ايها الذين امنوا شهاده شهاده
بينكم اذا حضر احدكم الموت حين الوصيه
اثنان حين الوصيه اثنان ذوى عدل منكم او
اخران من غيركم ان
انتم ان انتم ضربتم في الارض
فاصابتكم مصيبه الموت
تحبسونهما تحبسون
من بعد الصلاه فيقسمان بالله ان ارتبتم لا
نشتري به
ثمنا لا نشتري به ثمنا ولو كان ذا قربى
ولا نكتم شهاده
الله
انا اذا لمن
الاثمين فان عثر على انهما استحقا قى اثما
فاخران يقومان
مقامهما فاخران يقومان مقامهما من الذين
استحق عليهم الاوليان
فيقسمان فيقسمان بالله
لشهادتنا احق
شهادتهما وما اعتدينا انا اذا لمن
الظالمين ذلك ادنى ان ياتوا بالشهاده على
وجهه على
وجهها او يخافوا ان ترد ايمان بعد
ايمانهم واتقوا الله
واسمعوا واتقوا الله واسمعوا والله لا
يهدي القوم
الفاسقين يوم يجمع الله الرسل فيقول ماذا
اجبتم؟ قالوا لا علم لنا
انك انت علام
الغيوب اذ قال الله يا عيسى ابن مريم اذكر
نعمتي عليك وعلى
والدتك اذ ايدتك بروح القدس تكلم الناس في
المهد
وكهلا واذ علمتك الكتاب والحكمه والتوراه
والانجيل واذ تخلق من الطين كهيئه الطير
باذني فتنفخ فيها فتكون طيرا باذني وتبرئ
الاكمه والابرص باذني واذ تخرج الموتى
باذني واذ كففت بني
اسرائيل عنك اذ جئتهم
بالبينات فقال الذين كفروا منهم ان هذا
الا سحر
مبين واذ اوحيت الى
الحواريين ان امنوا بي
وبرسولي قالوا
امنا بالله واشهد باننا
مسلمون قالوا امنا واشهد
باننا
مسلمون اذ قال الحواريون يا عيسى ابن مريم
هل يستطيع ربك ان
ينزل هل يستطيع ربك ان ينزل علينا
مائده من
السماء قال اتقوا الله ان كنتم
مؤمنين قالوا نريد ان ناكل منها
وتطمئن
قلوبنا ونعلم ان قد صدقتنا ونكون عليها من
الشاهدين قال عيسى ابن مريم
اللهم ربنا انزل
علينا انزل علينا
مائده من
السماء تكون لنا
عيدا تكون لنا عيدا لاولنا واخرنا وايه
منك
وارزقنا وارزقنا وانت خير
الرازقين قال الله اني منزلها
عليكم فمن يكفر فر بعد منكم
فاني
اعذبه فاني اعذبه عذابا لا
اعذبه
احدا من العالمين
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
السلام
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط
الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واذ قال الله يا عيسى ابن مريم انت
قلت للناس اتخذوني وامي الهين من دون
الله قال سبحانك ما كان يك ما قال
سبحانك قال سبحانك ما كان لي ان قال
سبحانك ما يكون لي ان اقول ما ليس لي
بحق ان كنت قلته فقد علمته تعلم ما في
نفسي ولا اعلم ما في
نفسك انك انت علام
غيوب ما قلت لهم الا ما امرتني به ان
اعبدوا الله ربي
وربكم وكنت عليهم شهيدا ما دمت
فيهم
فلما توفيتني كنت انت الرقيب
عليهم وانت على كل شيء شهيد
ان تعذبهم فانهم
عبادك وان تغفر لهم فانك
انت وان تغفر لهم فانك انت العزيز
الحكيم قال الله هذا يوم ينفع الصادقين
صدقهم لهم جنات
تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها
ابدا رضي الله عنهم ورضوا عنه ذلك الفوز
العظيم لله ملك السماوات والارض وما
فيهن وهو على كل شيء
قدير بسم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله الذي خلق السماوات
والارض وجعل الظلمات
والنور ثم الذين كفروا بربهم
يعدلون هو الذي خلقكم من طين ثم قضى
اجلا واجل
مسم
تمترون وهو الله في السماوات وفي الارض
يعلم سركم
وجهركم ويعلم ما
تكسبون وما تاتيهم من ايه من ايات ربهم
الا كانوا عنها
معرضين فقد كذبوا بالحق لما
جاءهم فسوف ياتيهم
انباء ما كانوا به
يستهزئون الم يروا كم اهلكنا من قبلهم من
قرن
مكناهم في الارض مكناهم في الارض ما لم
نمكن
وارسلنا
السماء عليهم
مدرارا وجعلنا الانهار تجري من
تحتهم
فاهلكناهم بذنوبهم
وانشانا من بعدهم قرنا
اخرين ولو نزلنا عليك كتابا في قرطاس
فلمسوه بايدي
لقال الذين
كفروا لقال الذين كفروا ان هذا الا سحر
مبين وقالوا لولا انزل عليه ملك ولو
انزلنا ملكا لقضي الامر ثم لا
ينظرون ولو جعلناه ملكا لجعلناه
رجلا وللبسنا
عليهم ما
يلبسون ولقد استهزئ برسل من قبلك فحاق
بالذين سخروا منهم ما
كانوا فحاق بالذين سخروا منهم ما كانوا به
يستهزئون قل سيروا في الارض ثم انظروا كيف
كان عاقبه
المكذبين قل لمن
ما في السماوات والارض قل
لله كتب على نفسه الرحمه
ليجمعنكم الى يوم القيامه لا ريب
فيه الذين خسروا
انفسهم فهم لا يؤمنون
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وله ما سكن في الليل والنهار وهو
السميع العليم قل اغير الله اتخذ
وليا فاطر السماوات والارض وهو يطعم ولا
يطعم قل اني امر ان اكون اول من
اسلم ولا تكونن من
المشركين قل اني اخاف ان عصيت ربي عذاب
يوم عظيم من يصرف عنه يومئذ فقد رحمه وذلك
الفوز المبين وان يمسسك الله بضر فلا كاشف
له الا
هو وان يمسسك
بخير فهو على كل شيء
قدير وهو القاهر فوق عباده وهو الحكيم
الخبير قل اي شيء اكبر شهاده قل الله شهيد
بيني
وبينكم واوحي الي هذا القران
انذركم به ومن
بلغ اانكم لتشهدون ان مع الله الهه اخرى
قل لا اشهد قل
انما هو اله
واحد وانني
بريء مما
تشركون الذين اتيناهم
الكتاب يعرفونه كما يعرفون
ابناءهم الذين خسروا
انفسهم فهم لا
يؤمنون ومن اظلم ممن افترى على الله كذبا
او كذب
باياته انه لا يفلح
الظالمون ويوم نحشرهم جميعا ثم نقول للذين
اشركوا اين
شركاؤكم الذين كنتم
تزعمون ثم لم تكن فتنتهم الا ان قالوا
والله ربنا ما كنا
مشركين انظر كيف كذبوا على
انفسهم وضل عنهم ما كانوا يفترون
ومنهم من يستمع
اليك وجعلنا قلوبه وجعلنا في
قلوبهم وجعلنا على قلوبهم اكنه ان يفقهوه
وفي اذانهم
واقرا وان يروا كل ايه لا يؤمنوا
بها حتى اذا جاءوا
ك يجادلونك يقول الذين
كفروا يقول الذين كفروا ان هذا الا اساطير
الاولين وهم ينهون عنه ويون عنه وان
يهلكون الا
انفسهم وما
يشعرون ولو ترى اذ وقفوا على النار فقالوا
يا ليتنا
يا ليتنا نرد ولا نكذب بايات ربنا ونكون
من
الشاكرين يا ليتنا نرد ولا نكذب باياتنا
بايات ربنا ونكون من
المؤمنين بل بدى لهم ما كانوا يخفون من
قبل ولو ردوا لعادوا لمان نهوا عنه وانهم
لكاذبون وقالوا ان هي الا حياتنا
الدنيا وقالوا ان هي الا حياتنا الدنيا
وما نحن
بمبعوثين ولو ترى اذ وقفوا على ربهم قال
ليس هذا
بالحق قالوا بلى
وربنا قال فذوقوا العذاب بما
كنتم
تعملون قال فذوقوا العذاب بما كنتم
تكفرون قد خسر الذين كذبوا
بلقاء
الاخره حتى اذا
جاءتهم الساعه
بغته قالوا قالوا يا حسرتنا على ما فرطنا
فيها وهم يحملون اوزارهم على
ظهورهم الا
ساء ما
يزرون قد نعلم انه ليحزنك الذي
يقولون فانهم لا يكذبونك
ولكن الظالمين
بايات الله
يجحدون ولقد كذبت رسل من قبلك فصبروا على
ما كذبوا واوذوا حتى اتاهم
نصرنا ولا مبدل لكلمات الله ولقد جاءك من
نبا
المرسلين وان كان كبر عليك اعراضه
فان استطعت ان تبتغي نفقا في الارض او سلم
في السماء
فتاتيهم
بايه ولو
شاء الله لجمعهم على
الهدى فلا
تكونن من الجاهلين
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله وصحبه ومنه ومن تبعه باحسان يوم
الدين اما بعد ان شاء
قيام الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه وتعالى
سري الله سبحانه وتعالى
وباصهم يستغفرون
‏So will get up and ask
for as I mention in a topic that was
before mention in a topic that I mention
on
the fig have is and regardless of where
we mention that some have mention that
that a noral person you and me and
one that will
قيام
[Silence]
life
the was people
‏more necessary
حديث رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم افضل
الصلاه بعد فريض الصلاه صلاه الليل
بسصلاه بعد الفر بعد فض
الصلاه people have
3:30
and right
after you can do it and go
to count قيام
الليل حديث رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
عليه الصلاه
والسلام
عليه
قيام
الله من سائل
فوت هل من مستغفر فاغفر
له الله سبحانه
وتالى
اجابه
اجابه الحمد
‏any minut 10 minut before
upay notay 16 20
30 عليه toجد in order
of
two right soay
الله
[Silence]
انء
‏have said this before and this conusion
at that time is nothing else thinking
about when you get up at time there
nothing else thinking about no food no
you are lerally fighting your sleep
that's it fing your
sleep and you that fighting your sleep
الله
make
up for us who ask him that asking him
that make us people andcept
امين ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وكنا عذاب القبر
وقنا عذاب جهنم وكنا شر فته المحي الممات
وكنا شرف فت المسيح الدجال ربنا تقبل منا
انك انت السميع العليم وتوب علينا يا
مولانا انك تواب الرحيم وصلى الله على
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك ارحم
الراحمين اللهم امين اللهم امين اللهم
امين
[Silence]
استووا
اعتدلوا استووا
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد
رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
انما يستجيب الذين
يسمعون والموتى يبعثهم الله ثم اليه
يحشرون وقالوا لولا نزل عليه ايه من ربه
قل ان الله قادر على ان ينزل ايه ولكن
اكثرهم لا
يعلمون وما من
دابه في الارض ولا طائر يطير بجناحيه الا
امم
امثالكم ما فرطنا في الكتاب من شيء ثم الى
ربهم
يحشرون والذين كذبوا باياتنا صم وبكم حكم
في
الظلمات من يشا يضلله ومن يشاء يجعله على
صراط
مستقيم قل ارايتكم ان اتاكم عذاب الله او
اتتكم الساعه اغير الله تدعون ان كنتم
صادقين بل اياه تدعون فيكشف ما تدعون اليه
ان شاء
وتنسون ما
تشركون ولقد ارسلنا الى امم من قبلك
فاخذناهم
بالباساء
والضراء لعلهم
يتضرعون فلولا اذ
جاءهم باسنا تضرعوا ولكن قست
قلوبهم وزين لهم الشيطان ما كانوا
يعملون فلما نسوا ما ذكروا به فتحنا عليهم
ابواب كل
شيء حتى اذا فرحوا بما اوتوا اخذناهم بغته
فاذا هم
مبلسون فقطع دابر القوم الذين ظلموا
والحمد لله رب
العالمين قل ارايتم ان اخذ الله سمعكم
وابصاركم وختم على
قلوبكم من اله غير الله
ياتيكم به انظر كيف نصرف الايات ثم هم
يصدفون قل ارايتكم ان اتاكم عذاب الله
بغته او جهره هل يهلك الا القوم الظالمون
وما نرسل المرسلين الا مبشرين
ومنذرين فمن امن واصلح فلا خوف عليهم ولا
هم
يحزنون والذين كذبوا باياتنا يمسهم العذاب
بما كانوا
يفسقون قل لا اقول لكم عندي خزائن الله
ولا اعلم الغيب ولا اقول لكم اني
ملك ان اتبع الا ما يوحى الي قل هل يستوي
الاعمى والبصير افلا
تتفكرون وانذر به الذين يخافون ان يحشروا
الى ربهم ليس لهم من دونه ولي ولا شفيع
ليس لهم من دونه ولي ولا شفيع لعلهم
يتقون ولا تطرد الذين يدعون ربهم بالغداه
والعشي يريدون
وجهه ما عليك من
حسابهم من شيء وما من حسابك عليهم من شيء
فتطردهم فتط طردهم فتكون من
الظالمين وكذلك فتنا بعضهم ببعض ليقولوا
اهؤلاء من الله عليهم من
بيننا اليس الله باعلم
بالشاكرين واذا جاءك الذين يؤمنون باياتنا
فقل سلام عليكم كتب ربكم على نفسه
الرحمه انه من عمل منكم سوءا بجهاله ثم
تاب من بعده واصلح فانه غفور
رحيم وكذلك نفصل الايات ولتستبين سبيل
المجرمين قل اني نهيت ان اعبد الذين تدعوا
من دون
الله قل لا اتبع
اهواءكم قد ضللت اذا وما انا من
المهتدين قل اني على بينه من ربي
وكذبتم به ما عندي ما تستعجلون به ان
الحكم الا
لله يقص الحق وهو خير الفاصد
قل لو ان عندي ما تستعجلون به لقضي الامر
بيني
وبينكم والله اعلم
بالظالمين
الله سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
وعنده مفاتح الغيب لا يعلمها الا هو ويعلم
ما في البر
والبحر وما تسقط من ورقه الا
يعلمها ولا حبه في ظلمات الارض ولا رطب
ولا يابس الا في كتاب
مبين وهو الذي يتوفاكم بالليل ويعلم ما
جرحتم
بالنهار ثم يبعثكم فيه ليقضى اجل
مسمى ثم اليه مرجعكم فينبئكم بما كنتم
تعملون وهو القاهر فوق عباده ويرسل عليكم
حفظه
حتى اذا جاء احدكم الموت توفته رسلنا وهم
لا
يفرطون ثم ردوا الى الله مولاهم الحق الا
له الحكم وهو اسرع
الحاسبين قل من ينجيكم من ظلمات البر
والبحر تدعونه تضرعا
وخفيه تدعون
تضرعا وخفيه لئن انجانا من هذه لنكونن من
الشاكرين تدعونه تضرعا وخفيه لئن انجانا
من هذه لنكونن من
الشاكرين قل الله
ينجيكم منها ومن كل كرب ثم انتم تشركون
قل هو القادر على ان يبعث عليكم عذابا من
فوقكم او من تحت ارجلكم او يلبسكم
شيعا ويذيق بعضكم باس بعض انظر كيف نصرف
الايات لعلهم
يفقهون وكذب به قومك وهو الحق قل لست
عليكم
بوكيل لكل نبا مستقر وسوف
تعلمون واذا رايت الذين يخوضون في اياتنا
فاعرض عنهم حتى يخوضوا في حديث غيره واما
ينسينك الشيطان فلا تقعد بعد الذكرى مع
القوم الظالمين
وما على الذين يتقون من حسابهم من شيء
ولكن ذكرى لعلهم
يتقون وذري الذين اتخذوا دينهم لعبا ولهوا
وغرتهم الحياه
الدنيا وذكر به ان تبسل نفس بما كسبت ليس
لها من دون الله ولي
ولا
شفيع وان تعدل كل عدل لا يؤخذ منها اولئك
الذين ابسلوا بما كسبوا لهم شراب من حميم
وعذاب اليم بما كانوا
يكفرون قل اندعوا من دون الله ما لا
ينفعنا ولا يضرنا ونرد على اعقابنا بعد اذ
هدانا
الله كالذي استهوته الشياطين في الارض
حيران له
اصحاب يدعونه الى الهدى اتنا قل ان هدى
الله هو الهدى وامرنا لنسلم لرب
العالمين وان اقيموا الصلاه
واتقوه وهو الذي اليه تحشرون
وهو الذي خلق السماوات والارض
بالحق ويوم يقول كن فيكون قوله الحق وله
الملك يوم ينفخ في
الصور عالم الغيب والشهاده وهو الحكيم
الخبير
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واذ قال ابراهيم لابيه ازر اتتخذ
اصناما الهه اني اراك وقومك في ضلال مبين
وكذلك ذلك نري ابراهيم ملكوت السماوات
والارض وليكون من
الموقنين فلما جن عليه الليل راى كوكبا
قال هذا ربي فلما افل قال لا احب
الافلين فلما راى القمر بازغا قال هذا ربي
فلما اثل قال لئن لم يهدني ربي لاكونن
من القوم
الضالين فلما راى الشمس بازغه قال هذا ربي
هذا اكبر فلما افلت قال يا قوم اني
بريء مما
تشركون اني وجهت وجهي للذي فطر السماوات
والارض
حنيفا وما انا من
المشركين
وحاجه قومه قال
اتحاجوني في الله وقد
هدان ولا اخاف ما تشركون به الا ان يشاء
ربي
شيئا وسع ربي كل شيء علما افلا تتذكرون
وكيف اخاف ما اشركتم ولا تخافون انكم
اشركتم بالله ما لم ينزل به عليكم
سلطانا فاي الفريقين احق بالامن ان كنتم
تعلمون الذين امنوا ولم يلبسوا
ايمانهم بظلم اولئك لهم الامن وهم مهت
تدون وتلك حجتنا اتيناها ابراهيم على قومه
نرفع درجات من
نشاء ان ربك حكيم
عليم ووهبنا له اسحاق ويعقوب كلا هدينا
ونوحا هدينا من قبل ومن ذريته داوود
وسليمان ايوب ويوسف وموسى
وهارون وكذلك نجزي
المحسنين وزكريا ويحيى وعيسى والياس كل من
الصالحين واسماعيل واليسع ويونس
ولوطا
وكلا فضلنا على
العالمين ومن ابائهم
وذرياتهم واخوانهم
واجتبيناهم وهديناهم الى صراط
مستقيم ذلك هدى الله يهدي به من يشاء من
عباده ولو اشركوا لحبط عنهم ما كانوا
يعملون اولئك الذين اتيناهم الكتاب والحكم
والنبوه فان يكفر بها هؤلاء
فقد وكلنا بها قوما ليسوا بها
بكافرين اولئك الذين هدى الله فبهداه
مقتده قل لا اسالكم عليه اجرا ان هو الا
ذكرى
للعالمين وما قدروا الله حق قدره اذ قالوا
ما انزل الله على بشر من
شيء قل من انزل الكتاب الذي جاء به موسى
نورا وهدى للناس تجعلونه
قراطيس تجعلونه قراطيس تبدونها وتخفون
كثيرا وعلمتم ما لم تعلموا انتم ولا
اباؤكم قل الله ثم ذرهم في خوضهم
يلعبون وهذا كتاب انزلناه
مبارك مصدق الذي بين يديه ولتنذر ام القرى
ومن
حولها والذين يؤمنون بالاخره يؤمنون به
وهم على صلاتهم
يحافظون ومن اظلم ممن افترى على الله كذبا
او قال اوحي الي ولم يوحى اليه شيء ومن
قال سانزل مثل ما انزل
الله ولو ترى اذ
الظالمون ولو ترى اذ الظالمون في غمرات
الموت
والملائكه باسطوا ايديهم اخرجوا
انفسكم اخرجوا انفسكم
يوم تجزون عذاب الهون بما كنتم تقولون على
الله غير الحق وكنتم عن اياته
تستكبرون ولقد جئتمونا فرادا كما خلقناكم
اول مره وتركتم ما خولناكم
وراء
ظهوركم وما نرى معكم شفعاء
كم الذين زعمتم انهم فيكم
اولياء لقد تقطع بينكم وضل عنكم ما كنتم
تزعمون ولقد جئتمونا فرادا كما خلقناكم
اول مره وتركتم ما خولناكم وراء
ظهوركم وما نرى معكم
شفعاءكم الذين زعمتم انهم فيكم
شركاء لقد تقطع بينكم وضل عنكم ما كنتم
تزعمون الله
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ان الله فالق الحب
والنوى يخرج الحي من الميت ومخرج الميت من
الحي ذلكم الله فانا
تؤفكون فالق الاصباح وجعل الليل سكنا
والشمس والقمر
حسبانا ذلك تقدير العزيز
العليم وهو الذي جعل لكم النجوم لتهتدوا
بها في ظلمات البر
والبحر قد فصلنا الايات
لقوم
يعلمون وهو الذي انشاكم من
نفس واحده فمستقر
ومستودع قد فصلنا الايات لقوم
يفقهون وهو الذي انزل من
السماء
ماء فاخرجنا به نبات كل شيء فاخرجنا منه
خضرا
نخرج منه حبا
متراكبا ومن النخل من طلعها قنوان دانيه
وجنات وجنات من اعناب والزيتون
والرمان مشتبها وغير
متشابه انظروا الى ثمره اذا اثمر وينعه ان
في ذلكم لايات لقوم
يؤمنون وجعلوا لله
شركاء الجن
وخلقهم وخرقوا له بنين وبنات بغير علم
سبحانه وتعالى عما
يصفون بديع السماوات والارض انا يكون له
ولد ولم تكن له
صاحبه وخلق كل شيء وهو بكل شيء
عليم ذلكم الله ربكم لا اله الا هو خالق
كل شيء
فاعبدوه وهو على كل شيء
وكيل لا تدركه الابصار وهو يدرك
الابصار وهو اللطيف الخبير
قد
جاءكم بصائر من ربكم فمن ابصر فلنفسه ومن
عمي فعليها وما انا عليكم
بحفيظ وكذلك نصرف الايات وليقولوا درست
ولنبينه لقوم
يعلمون اتبع ما اوحي اليك من ربك لا اله
الا هو واعرض عن
المشركين ولو شاء الله ما اشركوا وما
جعلناك عليهم حفيظا وما انت عليهم
بوكيل ولا تسب الذين يدعون من دون الله
فيسب الله عدوا بغير
علم كذلك زينا لكل امه
عملهم ثم الى ربهم مرجعهم فينبئهم بما
كانوا
يعملون واقسموا بالله جهد ايمانهم لئن
جاءتهم ايه
ليؤمنن بها قل انما الايات عند
الله وما يشعركم انها اذا جاءت لا
يؤمنون ونقلب افئدتهم وابصارهم كما لم
يؤمنوا به اول مره ونذرهم في طغيانهم
يعمهون
الله سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
شفع
تستو الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى
الذي خلق فسوى والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج
المرعى فجعله
غثاء احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما
شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى ونيسرك لليسرى
فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من
يغشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من
تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه
الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم وموسى
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
بسم
الله
انا اعطيناك
الكوثر فصل لربك
وانحر ان شانئك هو
الابتر الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم
الله قل هو الله
احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده اللهم ان نشهد ان انت الله لا اله
الا انت الواحد الاحد الفرد صمد الذي لم
يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد اللهم
انت الحق ووعدك الحق ولقاؤك الحق وجنه
الحق ونار الحق وساعه الحق ونبينا حق
ونبينا محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم حق اللهم
بك اسلمنا وعليك توكلنا
واليك نبناه وبك خاصناه فاغفر لنا ما
قدمنا وما اخرنا فانت المقدم وانت المؤخر
وانت على كل شيء
قدير اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا فيمن
عافيت وتولنا فيمن توليت وبارك لنا فيما
اعطيت وكنا واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت
انك تقضي ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يذل من
واليت ولا يعز من عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر
لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وان لم
تغفر لنا وترحمنا لنكونا من
الخاسرين اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعف
عنا اللهم انك عفو تحب حب العفاو عنا
اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب العفو فاعفو عنا
اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين اللهم انصر الاسلام والمسلمين
في كل مكان اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين اللهم انصر دينك وكتابك اللهم
انصر نبيك محمد وعبادك
الصالحين اللهم ازل الشرك
والمشركين ودمر ر اعداء الدين يا قوي يا
عزيز اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار اللهم
اعتق رقابنا من النار اللهم اعتق رقابنا
من النار اللهم اعتق رقابنا ازواجنا من
النار وارحامنا من النار وابائنا من النار
وامهاتنا من النار ومن اوصانا واستوصانا
بدعاء الخير وادخلنا الجنه مع الابرار يا
عزيز يا
غفار يا عزيز يا غفار يا عزيز يا
غفار اللهم يا سامع الصوت ويا سابق الفوت
ويا كاسيا عذاما لحما بعد الموت اغفر
لجميع الموتى المسلمين الذين شهدك
بالوحدانيه والنبيك
بالرساله وماتوا على ذلك اللهم اغفر لهم
وارحمهم وعافهم وعف عنهم واكرم نزلهم ووسع
مدخلهم واكثلهم بالماء ثلج والبرد ونقهم
من الذنوب والخطايا كما ينقى ثوب الابيد
من التنس ومتعنا اللهم
باسماعنا
وابصارنا وقواتنا
ابدا ما
ابقيتنا واجعله الوارث منا واجعل ثهرنا
على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من
عادانا ولا تسلط علينا بذنوبنا من لا
يخافك ولا
يرحمنا اللهم عز جارك وجل ثناؤك وتقدس
اسماؤك اللهم لا يرد امرك ولا يحزن جندك
سبحانك بحمدك اللهم اعد المسجد الاقصى الى
رحاب
المسلمين اللهم اعد المسجد الاقصى الى
المسلمين اللهم عد المسجد الاقصى الى رحاب
المسلمين وارزقنا فيه صلاه قبل الممات يا
عزيز يا غفار يا اجود الاجودين يا اكرم
الاكرمين اللهم اصلح
احوالنا اللهم اصلح احوالنا واحوال
المسلمين
اللهم اسلح اولادنا واولاد المسلمين اللهم
اصلح اولادنا واولاد المسلمين اللهم اسلح
اولادنا واولاد
المسلمين يا حي يا قيوم يا حي يا قيوم
برحمتك نستغيث اصلح لنا شاننا كله ولا
تكلنا الى انفسنا طرفه
عين لا اله الا انت سبحانك انا ك من
الظالمين ين وصلى الله على محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك يا ارحم
الراحمين الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله